you used to be able to have like four
wives like if you were a king and
[__] where in the world can you do that
now I don't know but you can't do it in
America you know you just can't have
four wives right like isn't it like
against the law or something but like
kings used to just be like yo guess what
I love this one now so [__] it you know
and the other wife would be like okay
you know as long as she you
know my good sir I wonder how [__]
more annoying it
is right my wife is like hey after
Christmas let's go to the Bowl game in
Dallas mizo playing and I'm like how the
[__] do I get out of this too late baby
I already know what you're talking about
the missou game and the answer is I'll
see you when you get back no so imagine
saying that to like four different
women oh [__] there would be overlapping
[__] you know there's like there's that
antique con convention and you be like
oh [__] how do I get out of this well I
could say I got to go to the blll game
but I don't even want to do that how to
get out of that and you know what I just
I hope I get cancer but you know what
I'm excited I don't want to go to that
bow game but anyway go ahead we're going
to go n I'll see we get backo dude we
have two kid every decade or so if
anybody listening to this is from
Missouri knows missou every you know
everybody from Missouri because every
time I bring up somebody you're like
that person went to missou if they did
well they all go to B John Ham I know
about these
[__] you know what happened
sweetie I got hit by a truck you did
yeah and then just run into oncoming
traffic so you don't have to do anything
I don't know how well when you're the
king though what you say goes right I
respect you well I don't but you only
respect me because I don't give a [__]
about it no I respect you
because I respect you because you're my
husband and I'm trying to learn how to
let you just be you as long as it's not
hurting our family [__] I'm me
you know what I mean
we it would be great to get to the point
to where if you were just like some guy
who like was a branch manager at Wells
Fargo could have like two wives and
honestly I don't think I think women
could have multiple husbands too totally
sometimes life attacks you and you get
this victim mentality and you're like
[__] these
[__] and I be like that's where
I'm
headed like I'm I'm not this isn't a
sexist thing I in a way I'm like dude
maybe it might be the [__] if I if I had
another husb if we and I'll marry him
too dude I just as long as I don't have
to like jerk him or anything just have
him around have him bring the ornaments
downstairs and then back up again when
we decid to get another tree that you
went to get the with the other husband
and I'm just the guy at home chilling in
his [__] coffee shop in his
house you know waiting in line with the
other husbands oh God damn it bro come
on man you got the [__] her last night
can I just jump please can I get the I
want to get four shots over espresso and
you get that stupid peppermint drink
anyway bro you're a cuck well I guess we
kind of all are in a way aren't we your
aim for years and years and years and
years and years was to be the guy that
girls
[__] right yeah but that's what you
you look for that in a guy as being like
the holy grail for like what a woman
would want but it's just because she's
initially attract to that like dominant
energy doesn't mean that she actually
wants to like be with them or even that
she even likes them like I can think of
guys in my past that were just like
douchebags but like they were hot and
like you know whatever dude but like you
don't you never had sex with anyone
until I came along because I'm the
man that's
that's my wife would if she wanted to
see that's the thing though you think
like oh
you want your wife to have another
husband too to help CU here's what would
happen she'd get the guy she'd get the
guy who was like a little Pudgy that
would help that would be like the cuddle
guy and like the oh tell me about your
feelings guy but then she would also get
a ball player to marry her too and you'd
have to like come home to like some
[__] lineman and you're like God this
guy's [__] RI well linemen are fat as
[__] but like you
know a hockey player and you're like oh
he can fight he's ripped he's got such
good
balance and he's just like dude I'm
actually going to sleep in the bed
tonight you're like
G all right I'll take the
floor wide awake because you drank too
much coffee and
[__] you hear some long-haired [__]
Adonis freak just nailing her ah
whatever you know what sometimes you
choose to be mad cuz like my instinct is
to be like ah if somebody did that if
somebody like had sex with my wife I'd
be like well [__] that but then I'm like
ah [__] man you could choose to not be
angry you know you really could is't
that crazy about
anger if you just sometimes stop like
the [__] you get mad at the petty [__]
if you just stop you're like hold up
hold up that doesn't really piss me off
if I just kind of control myself yo
that's Bonkers I'm trying to be a little
bit of a more even keeled Larry David
you know what I'm saying and it's just
I'm just headed straight towards Larry
Davidsville and I I want to be a little
more forgiving a little more uh
openminded and openhearted and I'm just
not honestly babe if you think about
where you were three and a half years
ago to where you are now I would say
that's an exponential up it's a spiral
staircase true yeah true you're doing so
much better I am doing better we're
living and learning baby that's all life
is living and learning yeah it's not
about the destination it's about the
journey dude I hope I end up with
somewhere really cool though even though
it's not about the destination